ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Recently the
Huberman Lab podcast
hosted a live event at The
Wiltern theater in Los Angeles.
It was entitled The
Brain Body Contract.
The first part of the evening
was a lecture about science
and science-based tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
The second half was a
question and answer period,
in which the audience asked
me questions from the podcast,
or related to their
own interests or things
that they've gleaned from
social media, or just
general questions about mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And I answered those
questions for them.
We wanted to make the recorded
version of that question
and answer session
available to everybody,
regardless of who could attend.
So what follows is the
question and answer
period from The Wiltern
theater Brain Body Contract
live Huberman Lab event.
I want to be sure to thank
the sponsors from that event.
They were Eight
Sleep, which makes
smart mattress covers with
heating and cooling capacity.
I started sleeping on
an Eight Sleep mattress
cover about eight months
ago, and it is completely
transformed by Sleep.
I sleep so much deeper,
I wake up far less
during the middle of
the night, if at all.
And I wake up feeling far
better than I ever have even
after the same amount of sleep.
In fact, I love my Eight Sleep
so much that when I travel,
now I'm quite bothered that
Airbnbs and hotels don't
have Eight Sleep
mattress covers on them.
And I've even shipped my
Eight Sleep mattress cover out
to meet me in the location
that I arrived to so that I
get the best possible sleep.
If you want to try Eight Sleep,
go to eightsleep.com/huberman
to save up to $400 off their
Sleep Fit holiday bundle,
which includes their
new Pod 3 Cover.
Eight Sleep currently
ships in the USA,
Canada, United Kingdom,
select countries in the EU,
and Australia.
Again, that's
eightsleep.com/huberman.
I'd like to also thank our
supplement partner, Momentous.
They make the very highest
quality supplements.
They ship internationally, and
they've formulated supplements
as single ingredient
formulations that
match what is discussed on
the Huberman Lab podcast.
If you're interested in
any of those supplements,
please go to
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And now without further ado,
the question and answer period
from the Huberman Lab
live event in Los Angeles.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What occurs in the mind
body when you have ADHD?
Are there ways to address
it without medication?
Thank you for this question.
So attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder
used to be called ADD.
The hyperactivity part
is a little misleading.
And again I'm not
a clinician here.
Here's what we know
works for some people,
and yet there are
always going to be
side effects of any kind of
chemical manipulation, which
is that, we know that people,
kids, and adults with ADHD
actually have a tremendous
capacity to focus if they like
what they're focusing on.
You take a kid with
ADHD who can't focus
and you give them their
favorite video game
and they are a laser.
The threshold to access the
dopamine system is higher.
And dopamine has this
incredible ability
to focus the brain and other
aspects of the nervous system.
Certainly, if people
require medication,
I'm not going to tell you to
stop taking that medication.
But the focus training exercises
that have been explored mainly
in China, but they're starting
to be explored over here
as well, do seem
to be of benefit.
And these are as they sound.
They use them in schools in
China now, which are literally
visual focus exercises.
Your mental focus,
that is your ability
to focus on things cognitively,
follows your visual focus.
And of course your
stress will anchor your--
essentially put you in a
soda straw view of the world.
So yes, there are non
medication-based treatments.
By medication I'm assuming you
mean prescription medication.
There are of course
supplement-based medications
that will increase
dopamine mainly L-tyrosine.
Again, this is
something to think
carefully about before
you start tampering
with your dopamine system.
But it is the--
L-tyrosine is the
precursor to dopamine.
So it will raise
your dopamine levels.
But I believe, and
you'll hear me say this
as many times as necessary,
that one should--
if you can rely on
behavioral tools first,
then of course, sleep and
nutritionists are prerequisite.
Again, for all mental health,
physical health performance,
you simply can't neglect those.
And then and only
then if all of that
isn't working to rely on
supplement-based tools
or on prescription medication.
So it's clear that Vyvanse,
Adderall, Ritalin, et cetera
work for ADHD, but
some people choose
to rely on more subtle forms
of pharmacologic manipulation
like L-tyrosine.
And this focusing
exercise essentially
consists of spending
1 to 3 minutes trying
to maintain visual focus.
And yes, you are
allowed to blink.
I don't know why we tend
to stare at something
we don't blink.
But don't let your eyes dry out.
And that can increase your
ability to focus cognitively.
And it works.
And keep in mind that focusing
always involves a refocusing.
We covered a beautiful data
set, not collected by my lab
but by Wendy Suzuki's Lab at
NYU, that at roughly 10-minute,
it's actually 13-minute a
day meditation of the sort,
where you just focus
on your breathing,
has been shown to improve
focus significantly.
Why don't we hear
about this more?
Well she's now Dean of
Arts and Sciences at NYU
and all the students
are hearing about it.
Hopefully, they're doing it.
But it takes a little
bit of discipline
for some reason 10-minute
a day type meditation
is something that very few
people follow consistently.
But if you're looking for non
medication-based treatments
for ADHD, or you're somebody
who just struggles with focus,
the focusing exercise
or the meditation,
I just subscribed it can be
very useful, so say the data.
Yeah, thanks for bringing
up space-time bridging.
Are people familiar with
what space-time bridging is?
I haven't talked a lot about it.
OK, this is-- thanks
for bringing that up.
We actually have an episode
on meditation coming
up soon where I cover it.
And I talked about
it long ago and then
I kind of abandoned it because
well, we wanted more data
and it's a pretty
interesting technique.
If you think about the
nervous system and vision
in particular, but if you're not
a sighted person or you're low
vision, or no vision, you could
do this with your hearing.
But I'm going to assume most
people here are sighted.
If not just translate this
to the auditory system.
You have this incredible
ability to close your eyes
and focus, for instance, on--
people talk about the third eye
center, focusing right
behind your forehead.
Do you know why people do
that when they meditate?
The reason is that
you actually have
no sensation in your brain.
It's the one place to focus
your attention for which
you abandon sensation.
If I think about any portion
of my body or my breathing,
either I'm going to
sense what's happening.
I'm going to perceive
my inner landscape,
so-called interior
reception, or my outer.
If I look out into the world,
it's external perception.
When you focus your attention
with your eyes closed,
you do have to close your eyes
just behind your forehead.
You are focusing on your
thinking Sort of obvious,
but I don't-- at least to me it
never been stated that clearly.
Again, one of the
problems with some
of the more traditional
practices but also the problem
with science, is that there's a
shrouding of everything in very
complex language, which sucks.
Why is it suck?
Because it's a separator.
You eliminate the
number of people
that can be brought to
potentially useful practices.
And I don't like it when
people, including myself,
overuse mechanism and
descriptions of fancy phrases
to mask basic principles,
so simplest language
I think it tends to unify
people around the practices.
So when you focus on this
so-called third eye center,
or a spot right behind your
forehead or on your breath--
it's a little tricky
with the breath,
but when you focus on
your frontal cortex,
there's nothing to sense.
Because there's no
sensory neurons there.
There's no touch.
There's no pain.
Nothing.
That's why in these gory movies,
you can take the skull off
and-- while in neurosurgeries
they're poking around in there,
and the person's
playing a violin.
Like no anesthetic
No anesthetic.
Doesn't require anesthetic.
There's no sensory neurons.
You can't sense anything there.
So space-time
bridging involves--
it's essentially a
meditation, but it's really
a perceptual exercise.
I think that's where
we're going with this,
is it starts by
closing your eyes
and focusing on that
location for which there
is no sensation.
There's only thought.
And then opening your eyes
and focusing on a location
maybe about the
distance of your hand.
And you focus also
on your breathing.
So you sort of imagine a kind
of a tether between that.
You can split your attention
to these two locations.
You're thinking about
your body and you're
thinking about a
location outside of you.
And then while
continuing to think
about your body,
so-called intersection,
focus on your breathing,
you focus further out,
and then further out,
and then further out.
And then ultimately, you know
that little cartoon or meme
where they're like, we're just
a little blue dot floating
in a big universe.
And like it's supposed to make
all your problems go away.
It kind of works
because what you've done
is you've expanded
your perception,
and you go oh, yeah the stuff
that's happening in here
is really important
when I'm focused
on what's happening in here.
But when I'm focused
on what's going on
and the vastness of all
this, and we're just
a little pale blue
dot and all that,
it changes your perception.
Not just your visual
perception obviously.
Changing your visual
perception changes
your cognitive
perception, which changes
your emotional experience.
So the space-time bridging
is a perceptual exercise
where you step from
focusing internally
to focusing externally
at a short distance, then
a further distance, further
distance, further distance,
and then trying to
imagine yourself
in this larger landscape.
It sounds very mystical but it's
actually very neurobiological.
And it captures
something really amazing.
Why is the T in
there-- the time?
Space-time bridging,
because this is space?
But time is in there because
when you focus in close,
your slicing of time is finer.
You notice the
subtle fluctuations
in your breathing and things
that are happening up close.
Whereas when you focus further
out, your perception of time
actually changes, which
is why in panoramic vision
we are calm.
And when you think
about, we're just
a pale blue dot and we
mostly only live to about 85
or maybe 100 years old, and
then what's happening right now,
my boss being a jerk, and
all that doesn't really
matter because the
Earth is spinning
and all that kind of stuff.
Which is all true.
And it's the stuff of
philosophy and mindfulness.
And I think it's beautiful.
What you're really
doing is you're
changing your time perception by
changing your space perception.
So space-time bridging
is very useful
because most people get
locked at one step, one
of these stations, especially
under conditions of stress.
And people who have
trouble focusing-- and I'm
glad you brought this up
in this context of ADHD,
people have a hard time
focusing whether or not
they have ADHD or not,
tend to skip back and forth
between different
space-time domains,
as we call them in science.
So this is a simple
exercise that you can do.
Focusing internally then
stepping out externally,
and then stepping back in.
All the while paying attention
to your inner landscape
just simply by focusing
on your breathing.
It's a tool that we're
still collecting data
on in terms of its utility, but
people are already using it.
And I don't think of
it as a meditation.
I think of it as a
perceptual exercise.
Thanks for asking that.
As a teenager what
are five things
you would recommend to
physically feel my best?
I'm a 15-year-old surfer
who attends high school
and plays soccer.
It sounds like you're doing
a lot of things, right?
To physically feel your best.
So I'm going to grasp at some
context here that I'm not--
that's not within reach.
I'm assuming if you are
doing all these things you're
hopefully doing a bunch
of other things too.
And they're going
to be demands on you
that you probably some of
them you don't want to do,
school and things
like that, are going
to have varying levels of
joy and delight and demand
of things you don't want to do.
I don't want to default always
to the simplest of tools.
But I certainly think
that even as a 15-year-old
if you're not already getting
lots and lots of sleep,
that's going to be great.
Tell your parents
that I said you should
get lots and lots of sleep.
provided you're not
sleeping through classes,
I'm a professor after all.
I couldn't tell you otherwise.
I would say if I could travel
back in time as a 15-year-old,
I would encourage you
to cultivate some sort
of mindfulness practice.
I know this sounds
a little cliche,
but having some awareness
of your thinking
about your thinking is good.
But I'm actually
not going to say
sit down and meditate for 10
minutes a day, or do NSDR.
I'm actually not
going to tell you
that I think given how
plastic your brain is,
how much it's changing at
15, I would encourage you--
and maybe you would set a timer
for this, to actually develop
just a really keen awareness
of what stresses you out,
what relaxes you, what
delights, you et cetera.
And just to simply develop
an awareness of that,
because those are your antennae.
And I certainly had a
meditation practice as a youth,
mostly given to me, because
I was a little haywire
and I needed it.
And it worked pretty well.
But I think in
retrospect, what I
wish I had developed was more
of a sense of how I navigated
stress or things
and things I enjoyed
and things I didn't enjoy.
And I would just encourage you
to have a general awareness.
Try and detect and
learn about what
raises your adrenaline, what
raises your dopamine, what
raises your serotonin, and then
start thinking about tools.
But, again the
awareness is going
to be very valuable and gosh,
as a 15-year-old you are
in this amazing blessed period
of heightened neuroplasticity,
should we all be so lucky.
So enjoy it.
Next question please.
Clarity on adrenaline
regarding cold water.
Should we wait to feel
the rise of adrenaline,
the "get me out of here"
feeling and the fall of it
before bailing?
Yes, provided it
doesn't kill you.
I don't want to say cold water.
It's hard to kill yourself with
cold water, provide your head's
above and you're breathing.
But it's-- sorry, my podcast
producer's always like,
"I can't help that."
Anyway, it's a great tool.
And different days
it'll feel different.
So for instance, doing any kind
of adrenaline and deliberate
cold exposure, or adrenaline
increasing activity early
in the day, you might find
that you are more "resilient"
than later.
In other words, the wall like,
I really don't want to do this.
This is actually
interesting for I think
it extends beyond cold water.
Let's say you really don't
want to do something.
Pay attention to the
fact that maybe it's
not the right thing to do.
But assuming it's
something that you
know you should do but
you don't want to do,
you are already in the
first wall of adrenaline.
You don't experience
it necessarily
as heightened levels of stress.
You might experience it as
heightened levels of fatigue
or a hard time shifting on
that kind of activation state
that's required to
move through the thing.
But I do encourage you to
take advantage of that.
And we have an episode coming
out tomorrow actually that
answers questions like, should
you train if you're sick
and what if you travelling.
And there's context always.
But I think that you
do want to experience.
If you want to get the most
out of the cold water exposure
and to be more specific the
adrenaline, then you want
to get to that point of I
really want to get out of here,
but I know I can stay in safely.
But I really want
to get out of here.
And it's a little
hard to explain,
but there's just so much
learning in those short moments
about where your mind goes.
And this sounds very kind of
again, subjective and maybe
a little wishy-washy.
But you can realize great
things about yourself
in those moments.
You can find insight
Also keep in mind that
the degree of discomfort,
not just physical but
mental discomfort,
is directly predictive of
the pain to pleasure wave
that you'll
experience afterwards.
The reason it feels so good
when you get out of the ice bath
and you're showered off--
I always do the
warm shower after.
I don't do this
end on cold thing.
I don't know, It just
seems a little too painful.
And then take a warm shower
and then you feel great.
And that's the surge
of dopamine that we
know based on a paper
published in the European
Journal of physiology lasts many
hours, and it's a 100% to 200%
increase in dopamine.
It's not a subtle effect.
And then people say,
wait, is that dopamine
going to crash my
dopamine system?
No, because it's
a nice slow rise.
In fact, I am actually not aware
of many things besides love
and delight that can
create this long, slow arc
of dopamine lasting many hours.
Maybe you're aware
of other things.
If you are, let me know.
But it turns out that long
arc is a true anti depressant.
And my colleague at Stanford,
Dr. Anna Lembke who's
the head of our Dual
Diagnosis Addiction Clinic
has talked about in her
amazing book Dopamine Nation
about patients of hers that
have really helped themselves
along and out of the more
depressive phases of working
through addiction and in
just depression in general
through directed
cold water therapy.
So I'm obviously a fanatic
about it in the sense
that it's a powerful relatively
safe, if done properly.
Safe, if done properly,
way to modulate
your internal dopamine.
Hopefully, I answered
your question.
Next question please.
Sorry, I caught it raised it
went off the fall, as well.
Yes, I think you should
get out once you've
accomplished something.
Don't get out when you panic
unless it's dangerous, sorry.
How can you train your brain
to feel more confident moments
where you tend to
feel intimidated?
OK, these are hard question.
Because context is tricky
here, because I don't know what
the context is.
And confidence on short
time scales, and then
long time scales, so
confidence in school,
confidence in career,
those are long arc things.
Whereas confidence to be able to
do something in the short term
is different.
But remember those
action sequences
that trigger the
release of dopamine.
I've mainly talked about
the dark side of dopamine,
but I hopefully also talked
about the sort of upward spiral
that dopamine can cause,
mainly by thinking
about delight and things
that you really enjoy.
That carries over.
And I would say that
you want to micro slice
the demands of what's maybe got
you back on your heels a bit.
Actually a good friend of
mine who's here tonight,
I think also my
friend Pat, he has
a great way of
conceptualizing this, which
is for most all
endeavors we either
feel back on our heels,
flat footed, or forward
center of mass.
Like we can really do
something, we're flat footed,
we're back on our heels.
And sometimes getting
from back on our heels,
lets call that lack of
confidence to just on two feet,
and confident enough to move
forward or at least stay
in the game.
That's going to require you
could lean on different tools.
I can't say which would be
ideal for the circumstance you
have in mind.
But I do think that having
a way to calm yourself
will give you access to
more internal resources.
We know this.
This was something
I meant to bring up
during the discussion
about fear versus love,
et cetera, trying to
access delight and love.
When we are in a state of
fear or stress or anxiety,
the rule set, the options
available to us, and indeed
our creativity, is
greatly diminished.
And this has to do with the
way that the prefrontal cortex
interacts with an
area of the brain
called the insula, which relates
to our internal landscape.
And there's this
weird phenomenon,
which is that
normally, our brain--
our thinking brain and our
rule setting brain can--
it leads the brain parts that
control and pay attention
to how we feel internally.
And that's why for instance,
if you feel a little nervous
you can still do something.
At some point you
get stressed enough.
And we know this from work by
my colleague David Spiegel,
it reverses.
And these areas
of the brain that
are paying attention like
how flushed my face is,
or whether or not I'm
sweating, or my breathing,
actually start to shut down
creative decision making.
So I would say the way
to have more confidence
is to learn to
control that stress
and keep the part of your brain.
The prefrontal
cortex is that part
that can come up with
new rules that can
be funny that can be creative.
That keeps that
brain part leading.
The way to think about this
is, the prefrontal cortex
is sort of like the coach,
and the rest of your brain
are sort of like the players.
And if you get too stressed, the
players start to lead the game
and the coach follows, and
kind of drags them along.
So I would encourage you to
focus on real-time stress
modulation, and to
raise your stress
threshold using the sorts
of tools we talked about.
And to register your wins.
I didn't get into this
in too much detail,
but one of the amazing things
about the dopamine system
is that it's highly subject
to your interpretation.
If you tell yourself
that a fail was a win,
and you can see or conceptualize
some way in which that's
actually true, you get to
tap into the dopamine system.
You might think that's crazy.
You can cheat your own brain.
You can cheat your
own neurochemistry.
And indeed you can.
You can change the time,
space-time reference.
And we see this with examples
like Nelson Mandela or Viktor
Frankl.
You read their stories trapped
in little cells, confined,
imprisoned.
And they come up with new ways
to access the dopamine system
by now not thinking about
what they're not getting,
but thinking about
what they can control
in their immediate experience.
Many examples of this throughout
literature and history.
And the dopamine system
is the life force system.
I don't say that
in any loose way.
Dopamine is life force.
It's the wish and the
desire to continue.
It's persistence.
And so if you can think about
what might seem like a failure
and really spend
some time thinking
about not the potential
wins on the outside,
but how you can conceptualize
that as a potential win
internally, you really
do get to achieve
an internal chemical win.
And that chemical win sets
you up for more real wins,
hopeful that make sense.
It's incredible how
contextualize the dopamine
system is.
But if it weren't,
why would it matter
if we're talking about money or
mates or food or job or school?
You don't get 50 reward
systems and motivation systems.
You get one, and that's
the dopamine system.
Next question please.
What is the competing mechanism
behind bilateral eye movement,
EMDR, that helps resolve
psychological trauma?
The competing mechanism.
Well, let me try and
answer as best I can.
I'm not sure I understand the
full extent of the question.
But let me--
EMDR, moving your eyes
from side to side, right?
And then recounting a
trauma is a very common
and actually one of the four
approved treatments that
are behavioral for trauma.
So it's taken seriously in the
psychiatric and psychological
community for good reason.
It tends to work best for
single event traumas as opposed
to entire childhoods.
No joke there.
Some people have their entire
childhood that was traumatic.
Other people they experience
a single event trauma
or repeated periods of the
same or similar type of trauma.
Eye movements from
side to side have
been shown in a
number of studies
to very potently reduce
the activity of a brain
structure called the amygdala,
which most people are familiar
with, because of the character
from the Star Wars movie,
Amygdala.
There's a neuroscientist
somewhere on that team.
It is indeed a threat
detection center
and when you move through
space, not outer space,
but when you walk like
this your eyes actually
generate these subtle
side to side shifts,
unless you're focusing
on a specific target.
And my lab and
other laboratories
have found that leads to a very
potent quieting of the threat
detection system.
And then EMDR is
essentially a process
of pairing that calmer state
with no threat detection
system activated with the
recount of something that
normally would be
quite triggering.
So you've heard of
Pavlovian conditioning,
like a bell rings and the
animal gets fed and animal
salivate eventually, just the
bell will evoke the salivation.
You're doing the
reverse of that.
It's called behavioral
desensitization.
It has an underlying
mechanism, et cetera.
But the idea is to
pair a calm state
with recount of something.
It has been shown
to be successful.
There are people who think that
the side to side eye movements
and the recount of
trauma may actually be
invoking some form of hypnosis.
My colleague David Spiegel's
an expert in clinical hypnosis,
has appeared on my
podcasts, Rituals podcasts
and a few other podcasts.
And talks about, this it
is not stage hypnosis,
it's clinical hypnosis.
So there may be
something going on there.
EMDR-- again, some people
get great relief from it.
Other people don't.
What's kind of nice is
that this eye movements
from side to side or simply
taking a walk as long as you're
not looking at your phone and
not allowing your eyes to move
from side to side,
is a very good way
to shut down the fear
and stress system.
So taking a walk I think is
relaxing for obvious reasons.
And there are data
showing that part
of the reason why animals
scratch at the door
and want to go for a walk may
not actually be the exercise.
There's kind of an anxiety
and then an anxiety relief
that occurs.
Of course, they have to
go to the bathroom too.
One of Costello's
great joys in life
was just peeing on everything
outdoors, thankfully.
So the psychological trauma
rewiring, unfortunately there
haven't been a lot of brain
imaging studies looking
at this long term of
how well EMDR works.
What I think is going to
happen in the next few years
by the way, is it is not going
to be a discussion around,
should you do
EMDR, should you do
transcranial
magnetic stimulation,
should you do
behavioral therapy?
It's going to be
combination therapies.
Combination therapies, including
pharmacologic manipulations
to essentially give a
boost to the systems that
encourage neuroplasticity,
like dopamine and serotonin and
adrenaline.
And then also then perform EMDR.
And if you want to
talk about what's
happening in the landscape
of clinical trials
on some of the psychedelics,
I'm happy to talk about it.
They're still
illegal, but they are
being used in clinical trials.
And very interesting
stuff is happening there.
OK, next question please.
What new research
or interventions
are you most excited
about in the realm
of health and wellness?
So what I think is
going to be very
interesting in the
next few years really
reflects my memory
obsession that you've
seen a little bit of tonight.
But the thing that I think
is going to be most useful--
and I've seen this
in science before
and I think we're going to
see it in health and wellness.
It's that there are all these
tools and all these people,
and he's saying this
and she's saying that.
But what, we're going to
start paying attention to
is, what are the common themes?
And a broader and
more important theme
is going to be one of
modulation versus mediation.
What do I mean?
Well, if someone were to
pull a fire alarm right now,
and please don't, that
will shift our attention
and make it hard to
focus on what I'm saying.
And knowing me I'd probably
just stay up here talking.
Do we think that fire
alarms mediate attention?
No, they modulate it.
If it were very
cold in this room
like it was when we first got
here tonight, or arctic cold--
hopefully it's warmed up a bit.
It has and I'm so sorry.
So sorry.
Yeah, I attempted to-- yeah.
I almost thought
maybe we all just do
a bunch of breathing to heat
up like adrenaline release.
But these days getting
groups of people
to all breathe on each
other is not exactly a--
I can see that might go
the wrong way in terms
of what people interpret.
So the idea here is that
certain things directly
mediate something.
Like a physiological
side directly
calms you down quickly.
It mediates the
calming response.
Getting good sleep makes
you less easily triggered.
It modulates stress.
But is sleeping directly
mediating stress control?
No, and I think this
is really important.
And this brings up the
topic of the gut-brain axis.
The gut is rich with
these little bugs,
bacteria trillions
of them, which
is an eerie thought to me.
But also the surface of your
skin, the surface of your eyes,
you have a skin microbiome,
a nasal microbiome.
Every mucosal lining
has a microbiome.
In fact, think about this.
This is a crazy but
worthwhile tangent.
Have you ever bitten the
inside of your mouth?
It sucks, right?
And you get cut and it hurts.
But guess what, the
inside of your mouth
heals without a scar.
Think about that.
Weird, right?
You cut anywhere
else on your body,
and depending on
how well you heal,
and your age and your immune
status, you get a scar.
Your mouth is
filled with bacteria
and it's open to the world,
but the gut microbiome,
provided it's healthy,
provides an incredible ability
to heal quickly.
And I'm not somebody who's
done a lot of acupuncture.
I went a few times.
And now there's
interesting science
happening on acupuncture.
But what's the first thing
they do when you walk in there?
Let me see your tongue.
And then they go oh, yeah.
And they have this
cool intuition
that's not based on Western
mechanistic science.
It's more of an intuition
based on millions,
if not billions of
data points that have
been put into these charts.
It's pretty cool.
And what they are
looking at, I believe
and from what my colleagues who
work on microbiome tell me is,
they can look at the
pallor of your tongue,
in particular in the
back and get a sense of
whether or not the
microbiome there
is of the appropriate stuff.
But they don't go,
oh, lactobacillus.
Remember this all end
to illness, right?
But then, Oh you're just biotic.
Instead they get a sense.
Now, parents of
small babies learn
to detect all sorts
of things coming out
of essentially every
orifice of the child
as a readout of health
because the child doesn't
have language.
And a dog owners unfortunately
you want to do this too,
for better or for worse.
Probably for better, right?
So we have this intuition
about gut health.
But gut health would be
another example, where
it's very clear now that
fiber can be helpful
but it's mostly consuming
these fermented foods
that have been used for ages.
But low sugar fermented foods of
the natto, kimchi, sauerkraut,
kombucha, et cetera,
all these things
depending on which
culture you're in,
they come in different forms.
Certain yogurts, et cetera, that
allow the gut to be healthy.
And it modulates a
huge number of systems.
So I don't think
that you're going
to cure depression by
adjusting your gut microbiome.
But if your gut microbiota are
not well, and you improve that,
it will indeed shift the
neurotransmitter systems
of your brain and give
you a elevated mood.
That shouldn't come
as a surprise anymore.
But I think that the whole
world thinks like, gosh it must
be the serotonin in the gut.
No, it's actually
not serotonin gut.
It's that the gut microbiota
create chemicals that actually
become serotonin in the
brain, or become dopamine
in the brain.
And so I think that
the gut microbiome,
I would put in
the same category,
although not quite as important.
I would put it in the
category of like sleep.
It modulates a huge
number of other processes.
It doesn't mediate them.
, So sunlight, sleep,
healthy gut microbiome,
exercise, good nutrition,
social connection, these things
all create this general milieu
or environment of health.
I would like to see more
distinction between modulating
and mediating effects
and tools out there,
because I also see a lot
of unnecessary argument.
People are like,
there's no example
that improving your gut
microbiome cures depression.
Of course there's not.
But there are really
good examples.
If your gut microbiome
is off that improving
it can improve mood,
which depending
on where you are on that
spectrum of depression
can really relieve things.
So I think that the
future of health,
we hear so much about
personalized medicine
and matched to your genome.
But we don't even
have the basic.
Most people don't even
have the basics right.
And if you watch or listen
to the podcast long enough,
hopefully certain themes
start to repeat themselves.
But a key theme that
you learn in science,
you teach your students, does it
modulate or does it mediate it?
You need to be careful
with your language there.
And there's great information,
or as we say, interpretation
power there.
If you understand
the difference then
I think we can go a long way
by making that distinction
modulating versus mediating.
There are probably other
things that modulate health
that I'm overlooking
now just because
of the flow that I'm in.
The CoolMitt.
Yeah, the CoolMitt.
Palmer cooling.
OK, I promised to talk
about Palmer cooling.
Well, I'll do it now.
Palmer cooling they
changed the Q&A format.
What can I say, this is like
teaching in the classroom.
All right, very briefly.
The Palmer cooling, which
is essentially placing--
you can cool the core
of the body most quickly
by placing cold objects on the
hands, the bottoms of the feet,
or on the top of
the face, because
of the arrangement
of vasculature.
Normally, you've got this
arteries, capillaries,
veins things, but at those
locations in the body,
you skip the capillaries
and you can basically--
you're not really
passing cooling the body,
but you're cooling off the
core of the body more quickly.
And, if you do that in
between sets of exercise
or during a run or cycling
you can dramatically
increase your
ability to continue.
I actually use the CoolMitt
for cognitive work.
But you don't need a CoolMitt.
Sorry, guys.
You can just get a thing of ice
water or just very cold water.
And I know it sounds
trivially easy,
but you're actually
just cooling your core
by putting your hands or
even one hand on a relatively
cold thing of water or ice.
But not so cold that it
constricts the vasculature
there.
This is the incredible work of
my colleague at Stanford Dr.
Craig Heller.
Why wouldn't more people
do this if you can
double the amount of endurance?
Believe it or not.
Or double the number
of sets of exercise
you can do or feel more alert
and do more cognitive work.
Why wouldn't more people do it?
Because people just don't do it.
And it sounds crazy.
It really sounds crazy,
but it's a real thing.
And I wish more
people would do it.
The athletes at Stanford do it.
People in the military do it.
So people who know and
they use it, enjoy it.
It's just it's almost like
seems to off target from what
you're trying to accomplish.
I don't know, for
some reason, people
are finally onboard breathing
like in a specific way
as a useful tool.
A few years ago no
one was into that.
I mean, just think of
how far we've come.
It's incredible.
People are talking about
psychedelics, meditation,
breathing.
I think the pandemic
for all its pains
and, you know,
what a challenging
period for all sorts of reasons,
did wake people up to the idea
that you have to take
control over your health,
because there's no magic
fairy coming to do it for you.
And with all due respect there's
no government agency that's
going to drop off the kit
at your front door of like,
here's how you take
good care of yourself.
So it just not going to happen.
And it wouldn't happen
under any circumstances.
So it's a personal
responsibility issue.
All right.
What lessons from skateboarding?
The failure part.
The failure,
failure, or failure.
I mean, for me skateboarding--
never was a good skateboarder.
I still have close
friends in that community
and our photographer
and a guy who
does all the visuals
and the other guys
do the visuals for our podcast,
Mike Blabac, Chris, and Martin,
all of that community.
I think that for me that
community was really--
as Mike will sometimes say,
skateboarders hate everything,
meaning they have a very
high threshold for what
they consider acceptable.
It's not just what you do.
It's how you do it.
Super important.
And I think in
neuroscience, there
are a lot of-- there's
a lot of stuff.
In science in general,
there are so many papers
and there are so
many experiments.
How do you navigate
that landscape?
I think it helped me
develop a sense of taste.
But the taste that
I'm referring to
is not necessarily
a taste of which
science is cool or not cool.
That too, but it came
through a few times
tonight when I was
talking about my mentors.
I picked back then
skateboarding because I really
liked the people.
And also you didn't need
your parents to go to a game.
And so that worked for me.
And you could kind of
make your own schedule.
And I do think it's very
important to the extent
that you can, in science
and in everything,
to surround yourself
with the kinds of people
that you just really
enjoy being around.
And so to me, the
podcast, running a lab,
feels a lot like skateboarding.
It's the same energy.
It's the same neurochemical
systems firing, so that's--
yeah, that one.
Next?
Favorite Feynman.
Oh, I know that's inappropriate.
I do have a Feynman story,
but it's inappropriate.
Darn it.
Damn.
Maybe some time.
This is why I don't drink.
Good decision making.
Well, I read all
of Feynman's books.
So I had the pleasure
I never met him.
He was dead before I was born.
But my dad did.
And he had good Feynman stories
and they were inappropriate.
So the cool thing about Feynman
was that he didn't really
care if people understood
the specifics of what
he was talking about.
He just wanted
people to get turned
on to how amazing physics was.
And he loved general principles.
And one of the
things-- the example
that sometimes given out.
I don't know how many of you're
familiar with the Feynman
books.
But surely, you're
joking Mr Feynman
or what do you care what other
people think, all of that
stuff it's wonderful.
He picked locks.
When he worked at
Los Alamos Labs,
they were working on the bomb.
And he basically-- well,
there and elsewhere.
And every morning the
offices used to come in
and he would spread all the top
secret papers out on the floor.
He would break into
the safes at night.
And then they were
perplexed who could do this.
And he liked safe cracking.
Literally like national
security secrets just
for fun, prankster.
He also bongo drummed naked
on the roof of Caltech.
And he did most of his writing
of theorems in strip clubs,
in fact.
Learnt to draw late
in life, was really
into flotation tanks,
and very curious about
but never did psychedelics.
That's as I understand.
But one of the cool
Feynman factoids
is that when he
was a kid, he talks
about when he was a
child that his dad used
to take him birdwatching.
And he'd say, oh, well
that's a whatever scrub jay
and that's whatever thrush and
that's the-- and his dad said,
no don't cloud your mind
with naming and taxonomy.
That's not meaningful.
Because then what
if it's different?
The pigmy thrush or the
lesser or this or that.
The more important
thing is to start
to identify principles of
why certain birds behave
one way and certain
birds behave another.
And to start finding
the commonalities
and the regularities.
And that's a theme that
I obviously tonight
have tried to impose.
And it's actually something
that I can't do in podcasts,
necessarily because I can't
thread across 40 episodes.
Or something like
that in the same way
that I could in an
evening like this.
So that's an appropriate
Feynman story.
Also he just seemed
like a delightful guy.
And he's kind of cool.
He's a little bit street,
he had the thick accent.
He was from Far Rockaway, but
he didn't really care much what
people thought, or he did
and he pretended he didn't.
Care for when
people tell you they
don't care what people think.
I think he did to the extent
that it still allowed him
to get the message out there.
OK, next question please.
My horse.
Wow.
I love this.
I delight in all things
animals, but especially horses,
because my high school
girlfriend had a horse.
And they do that thing where
people go, oh you know, horses
can detect how-- they know
more about you than you know.
And then I get onto the horse,
and the horse like this this
and this.
And it's like a litmus test.
Having a girlfriend with a horse
was very intimidating for me
actually.
I felt like I had to
compete with the horse.
She spent all this time with
the horse, it's very large.
Anyway, eventually
I broke the horse.
OK, my horse does the double
inhale, long exhale often.
He's a bit of a stressed guy.
Warm blood?
Yeah, warm blood.
I used to work at the barn.
I used to shovel manure
and work at the barn.
She brought her
horse to college. .
I actually followed
her off to college
I never would have
gone to college
if she hadn't gone to college.
And the horses are
interesting animals.
They do tell you a lot.
The horse does the double
inhale, long exhale often.
He's a bit of a stress guy.
Do you suppose this
physiological stress regulator
transcends species?
Absolutely.
In fact, I mentioned warm blood.
I have a colleague at
Stanford and she's amazing.
Her name is Sue
McConnell and she
is an expert in dog
genetics, so you
can imagine I'm always
asking her questions.
And we talk about dogs and we
talk about horses because she
also--
I thinks she raises warm bloods.
And you hear about hot
bloods and warm bloods.
And also, if you have any
familiarity with dogs,
there are dogs like Costello,
or like a nuclear bomb
could go off and Costello
might open an eye.
That's the bulldog,
economy of effort.
They're not going to get
activated unless there's
a reason to do it.
They are very, as we call
it, parasympathetic dominant.
That seesaw of autonomic
arousal is just really relaxed.
Getting them into action
is more of an effort.
There are other animals
like the whippet
or the Italian greyhound.
Like they're always cold, that
are very sympathetic dominant.
And then of course, within
a breed or within a species
there's a range.
And humans also,
are within a range.
I think anyone who's had
children will tell you he
or she has been like
this since birth.
Calm, easygoing, or like
really easily stressed.
I think that seesaw, we didn't
get into tonight too much.
But there's a concept with
the autonomic regulation
of a hinge.
So don't think so much
about being really stressed
out or really relaxed.
But certain animals,
the hinge is
tighten so that the
seesaw just kind of tilts
mellow like Costello.
A bulldog almost seems
like a different animal
than a whippet.
They're so very different.
And within the
category of horses--
and I'm not an expert
in horse genetics,
but they are
selected for not just
for their physical attributes,
but for their psychological or
temperament attributes.
And you see this in dogs too.
In fact, the reason
I picked Costello,
and Elvis can verify
the stories, I read--
I wanted a dog
for so many years.
And I went there and there
were all these puppies.
And I was like I heard you need
to take them in the other room
one by one.
And then if it barks for
its siblings, you're like,
oh it's a healthy puppy.
So I walk in and all the dogs
are running around like crazy.
It was right around
Christmas time, right Elvis?
And they're running around and
then there's one in the back.
And he's taking
advantage of the fact
that all the other
ones are running.
He's just eating out
of all of their bowls.
And I was like, I want that one.
So I took that chubby little
bastard in the next room
and I thought, OK, he's going
to bark for his siblings.
And he lay down
and he took a nap.
And I was like, this one.
I want this one.
Why did I want that one?
Well, this completes
the principle
which is, I wanted a dog like
that because I'm not like that.
And I was very interested in
a dog I could take care of,
but also a dog that would help
regulate my nervous system.
And so for me having
a dog like that
as opposed to a
whippet or something
that was going constantly
around is a very calming effect.
And to this day memory of his
snoring still puts me to sleep.
So I think that your
horse probably has--
it kind of idles a
little bit higher.
Think about the rpm.
You know, revs a little bit
higher at a given speed--
more rpm at a given speed.
That's the way I think
about the autonomic system.
How do you reset that?
Well, this is why a lot of
exercise is good, right?
And certainly my
girlfriend's horse was crazy.
It was gelded late.
And it was crazy.
I almost said nuts but
that's like a bad pun
so it was not nuts
but it was crazy.
It was gelded late.
Next question.
Is there any science behind
staying motivated or developing
discipline?
Oh, so this represents
the higher tier
of where I think
things are going
to go in the next
few years, where
we're going to start seeing
this convergence of psychology
and biology, where we can
get to these harder concepts.
I like to think that
we can stay motivated
through a simple process that
now will make sense to you.
Because the last thing I covered
was toggling back and forth
between our ability to
be gritty and linen,
kind of in friction, maybe
even a little anger, fear,
competitiveness, et cetera.
That kind of grinding in.
But that the more
sustaining fuel,
the sort of hybrid version,
a hybrid fuel model
would be one in which
you can access that.
But that's a depletable
and not so renewable
resource without a lot of rest.
Meaning, working hard out of
anger, determination, and kind
of grit will work, but
when you are depleted
you have to stop
for a long while.
Whereas if you can access
this delight system,
which is really one of
dopamine and serotonin, both.
In other words, and I want
to think of a different way
to put this, but to try
and think about what
sorts of things and tools allow
you to be and feel most loving,
I know it sounds weak.
But it's anything
but weak to be most
loving in the verb sense of the
word toward what you're doing.
I actually used to use
this trick in college when
I'd encounter a topic I hated.
I would tell myself I'm really--
I'm just going to
fall in love with this
by trying to find
the gems within it.
Sometimes it worked.
Sometimes it didn't.
But the wish to do it
that way as opposed to OK,
I'm just going to
grind this out,
at least for me at the
time was a powerful tool.
So motivation and--
discipline is a tricky one.
That's sort of the
just do it thing.
You need tools to modulate your
stress and to get your sleep--
do all the basic things right.
Set the right context for
you to be in your best
chance of being disciplined.
And that itself is its
own form of discipline.
But in terms of
continual motivation
you're not going to manage to
go against the grain for very
long.
People have managed to
go against challenge
for a very long time--
for a very long times.
In fact, I was reading recently
about the psychology of people
who've been kidnapped.
And they have this odd
trick that they used.
Have you heard about this
is sort of like Stockholm
syndrome?
But they actually convinced
themselves to fall in love
with their captors.
And then they come up with
new ways to escape them,
which is kind of cool.
So there's something
about mentally feeling
like you're trying to go
from back on your heels
to flat footed.
That's very
energetically costly.
So again, these systems are
very susceptible to what we call
context or top down regulation.
Hopefully that helps.
I know it's a
little bit abstract.
I wish I could give
you a 1-minute exercise
or make you motivated.
But we do talk about tools to
get adrenaline going and things
like that.
But spend some time
thinking about what
would allow you
to sustain effort
through positive feelings.
It's not a light concept at all.
Next question please.
What would be your
biggest piece of advice
for achieving one's dreams?
Boy!
That's a tough one.
Again, this is going to
be a little abstract.
I'm a believer in this idea
kind of a seed message.
Robert Greene has
talked a lot about this,
that we can all kind of
think back to a event
or stage of our life.
Typically it's before
puberty for other reasons
that are kind of interesting.
But where we delight
in something.
So for me it was fish.
And obviously now I don't
need to work on fish.
It wasn't about the fish.
I hope that came through.
I mean aquaria are really cool,
but it's not about the fish.
It was something about
the way they moved.
It was something about the way
that it tickled my excitement.
I used to get dropped off
at this little pet shop
in California Avenue
called Monette's Pet Shop.
And my mom used it as childcare.
She would drop me off
there and I had this book
and I would log all
the tropical fish,
and which ones could be with
which ones, and then I would--
I was obsessed.
But for me it was
something about organizing
and being able to make
reliable predictions.
It was about parsimony.
It was about principles
as opposed to--
and the colors delighted me
and all that kind of stuff.
The equipment delighted
me, but then I hit puberty.
And then it was something else.
And then I went to college
and it was something else.
And I got a girlfriend
So it changes over time.
But this is why I recommend to
that young 15-year-old person
that they learn to tap into that
sense of like Oh, this is cool.
Like this feels cool.
I know not everyone
else thinks it's cool.
Maybe they do.
Like this feels good.
I actually have a somatic
experience of this.
I'm not a very semantically
oriented person.
I'm more up here.
But I actually know if
I'm on to something,
if this left arm just
kind of starts fidgeting,
it's like I want to move
or like some people--
you can start to identify
ways in which you suddenly
have this positive energy.
It's not a fear energy.
It's almost like a
magnetism to things.
And just don't be
confused or misdirected
in thinking that
it's that thing.
It's that energy or that
attraction to something
that feels right that is your--
I wish we had these
divining rod to find water.
That's your tool.
It's like antennae, you
want to grow your antennae.
So how do you
follow your dreams?
Well, I never thought
I'd do a podcast.
I never thought I'd
become a neuroscientist.
You have to be willing
of course, to take risks
and to iterate quickly,
but not so quickly
that you fail out of
the game, et cetera,
if you do get back
in, et cetera.
But it's really about
developing an awareness.
Now, the key thing is you're
not going to find this
by going up a mountain and
sitting there or waiting
for your passion to
just kind of rock it in,
or piano fall onto your head.
It's not going to
happen that way.
You have to interact
with the sensory world
and different kinds of people.
And you have to be a little bit
of a adventurer in a safe way,
of course.
An adventure and learn
to recognize the signals.
And some people are
very in tune with this.
There's an amazing podcast
with Rick Rubin recently
on Joe Rogan's
Podcast where he talks
about the creative processes.
Kind of this-- it
seems like whatever's
going on in that beard of his
just connects to the world.
And he can just like--
there, that's where you
need to go and that's--
But that's part of the magic,
is you don't really know.
And because it's all energetic--
it's all energetic.
And when I say
energetic, I don't
mean in the mystical sense.
I mean you have
to learn to sense
those fluctuations in energy.
Some people can sense
them very easily
because they're very mellow.
And if something gets
them really excited
they notice as a big delta, as
we say in science, big change.
Other people they ride
kind of high all the time.
And so everything
is exciting to them,
and they miss a lot of
the subtle fluctuations
in what's really special
and right for them.
In fact, mania is
characterized by hyper
elevated levels of dopamine
and everything is a good idea.
And depression is the opposite.
Nothing is a good idea.
Nothing's going to work.
And those are the extremes.
And those are rough
conditions obviously.
But for most people,
it's about learning
to detect those
subtle fluctuations.
And every time-- every single
time you find somebody who is
exceptional at their craft
and doing well in life--
there are a lot of people who
are exceptional at their craft,
but not necessarily
doing well on the whole.
Those people have a
kind of intuition about
what feels good to them.
This year's Nobel Prize
winner in chemistry
is my colleague,
Carolyn Bertozzi.
And all I know of
her, except the fact
that she's an amazing
chemist, is they
did this interview with her.
And she said that when everyone
would go out in college
she was finding excuses
to stay home and read
organic chemistry.
Now, that to me sounds
like a bad night.
But for her it was pure delight.
And she's wired for that.
And I think her
work is going to be
vitally important and
transformative for humanity.
I really do.
So how do you succeed
in chasing your dreams?
You succeed in
identifying what they are.
But you don't know
at the outset.
You want to find the energy
to find the right path
and continually course correct
when you will undoubtedly
be off your path.
That's essentially
what I've done.
I still look for the
feeling of delighting
in Costello or the cuttlefish.
That's what I'm looking for.
It's not a template I have to
match, but that's my like, oh,
yeah I know what
that feels like.
It's like a texture.
It's like if you think about
a bunch of different textures
of sandpaper, it's like this
one that just feels really good.
And so you're comparing
everything to that,
because the system that
involves all these chemicals,
you'll find it if you learn
to pay attention to it.
But you won't find it sitting,
staring at your belly button
or going up a mountain.
You have to be in sensory
experience in order to find it.
Reflection is good but you
need to get into action.
Wow.
All right well.
OK, so psilocybin.
Opinion of the psychedelics.
Generally, we just had an
episode with my colleague Nolan
Williams, who's a triple
board certified neurologist
psychiatrist.
It's a fun thing about
working at Stanford.
It's also very humbling
because you're like,
whoa who are these people?
They have three
board certifications.
The psilocybin-- first of
all, not for everybody.
People with psychosis,
it is still illegal
decriminalized in
certain places.
So obviously the
cautionary notes
people who have drug addiction
issues or other kinds
of addiction issues need to
be thoughtful about diving
into a neurochemical
landscape like that.
But it does appear that
the clinical trials
on one macro dose.
This is what's
interesting to me.
A lot of people talk about
micro-dosing psilocybin,
but the data at least according
to Matthew Johnson, who is also
on the podcast, the
data for micro-dosing
are not really there, frankly.
The data on single session macro
dose, the sort of heroic doses
that have been talked about
in the psychonaut community
for a depression and
to some extent PTSD,
and for eating disorders and
sort of end of life preparation
are quite encouraging.
In fact, the current data
suggests that about 2/3
of people achieve lasting
relief from one session.
Now, keep in mind those are
guided sessions with physicians
in the room, et cetera.
I do think there's a potential
hazard of all psychedelics,
which is they alter--
this includes MDMA
or especially MDMA,
they alter the chemical
landscape in you,
such that a lot of
things can serve
as attractors in that state.
Meaning you can get really into
the sound of music in an MDMA
session, feel connected
to that, and waste
the opportunity for some more
meaningful transformative
rewiring.
And I do think that's
worth paying attention to.
So that's the usefulness of
having a therapeutic guide,
as they can continually
steer you back to what
at least for you is the
more meaningful work.
But it's very encouraging.
And Nolan Williams,
who I trust, is again
triple board certified M.D. Said
that in the studies of lifetime
perceived individual and
societal risk, of all
the compounds out there
except for caffeine,
psilocybin is at the
bottom of the list.
Whereas things like
heroin, cocaine, alcohol,
methamphetamine sit at
the top of the list.
Actually, alcohol quite high
on that list at certain amounts
of consumption.
So I'm very excited
about what's happening
in the landscape of
psilocybin, but I'm not
so excited about the
micro-dosing data.
Very excited about the
single heroic dose data.
One interesting
thing there perhaps,
what seems to be
the unifying feature
of a successful psilocybo--
psilocybin, excuse me session,
is that at some point
the person feels
as if it's like too much
of a autonomic thing.
It kind of get to
this point and then
they are encouraged to "let go."
And I'm fascinated
by this concept
of letting go, because
I'm a neuroscientist.
We don't know what
that means, but it
seems like being able to ride
the wave of autonomic arousal
from top to bottom.
Seems to be very powerful
for trauma and depression
treatment.
And this is interesting.
A lot of people think that one
of the major issues in humans
nowadays is we're stressed
about a lot of things.
But we never actually get to go
into the full stress response,
and then let it relax again.
And catharsis was
big at one point.
Scream therapy, Steve Jobs
is going to scream therapies.
That whether or not catharsis is
healthy or not has been debated
but the data are kind
of pointing to the fact
that it may be provided
that the catharsis is not.
Obviously someone damaging
themselves for somebody else.
So maybe we should all
be screaming a lot more.
Why does my desire
to eat disappear
after I use the sauna?
Oh, interesting.
I can go in hungry and get
out with no desire to eat.
I can only speculate.
The sauna or any kind of
deliberate heat exposure
that's uncomfortable releases
this molecule dynorphin.
This is actually
the same molecule
that's released under conditions
of alcohol withdrawal.
It makes you feel
agitated and not good.
And then there's this rebound.
The way it feels
good is later, it
causes this upregulation in the
so-called mu opioid receptors.
So the chemicals that you
have, your so-called endogenous
opioids, not the
opioids that are
related to the opioid crisis.
But the ones that
you naturally make
are able to have a more
robust effect after the sauna.
Dynorphin is an
appetite suppressant
and for reasons related to
kind of general discomfort
in the body.
So that's the only
reason I can speculate.
There are a number
of other things
that sauna does including
massive increases in growth
hormone provided you
don't sauna too much.
So if you do it once a week
four 20-minute sessions spaced
five minutes apart, you get
these enormous increases
in growth hormone.
If you start doing
it more often you
get still significant,
but smaller increases
in growth hormone.
And my team, this is how
the podcast goes too.
At some point Rob just
goes, it's enough.
So if you think the
episodes are long now,
they'd be a lot longer.
Listen, I just want
to-- before we part,
I know it's a Sunday night
and people have to go,
I want to thank everyone
for coming out tonight.
I know that at least for me
I'm still sort of baffled,
but pleasantly so that people
are interested in investing
time to come out and hear
hours of a nerd like me
and talk about
science and tools.
And I'm delighted that
people are hopefully gleaning
some useful information.
Please do pass along
the information.
I didn't invent this stuff
as I mentioned before.
I was not consulted
on the design phase.
I have no domain over it.
This is the stuff
of mother nature.
And whatever other beliefs
you have, they're here in us.
And of course, I'd be remiss
if I didn't finish by saying,
have a wonderful
night and thank you
for your interest in science.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]